Musik
Die Technik funktioniert heute. Es ist tatsächlich gut, wenn so ein Amateurprojekt irgendwann so einen Status erreicht hat, dass man sich nicht mehr auf dem, unsere Technik ist scheisse, Ausrede ausruhen kann, weil die Technik einfach so gut ist. Wir haben keinen Delay mehr, wir haben gar nicht. Kein Delay, die Funkverbindung ist einwandfrei, es gibt kaum Feinstoff in der Luft heute, eigentlich, wir haben keine Ausreden, deswegen. Und ich habe mir sanft und sorgfältig angehört und man hört tatsächlich teilweise, dass sie auch einen Delay haben. Und man hört auch, dass wenn Jan leise ist, dass man hört man Olli reden in so einem ganz frequenten Bereich, wo man sagt, da hört man den Kopfhörer von Jan, auf jeden Fall. Und das ist natürlich dann peinlich für uns jetzt. Ich meine, das ist ja diese legendäre mystische Frage, sind die im gleichen Studio, ja oder nein?
Nein. Führer von Jan, auf jeden Fall. Und das ist natürlich peinlich für uns jetzt. Ich meine, das ist ja diese legendäre mystische Frage, sind die im gleichen Studio, ja oder nein, bei Sand und Sorgfältig. Aber, was ich mir letztens gedacht habe, manchmal interagieren sie ja mit dem Aufnahmeleiter oder mit der Aufnahmeleiterin oder halt im Studiopersonal. Und da haben sie letztens, hieß es, ah, was macht die denn gerade? Und dann haben beide gleichzeitig gesagt, ah, sie zeigten Stinkefinger. Und da dachte ich mir, wie funktioniert das denn? Das sind so Gags, die auf der Strasse liegen. Das sind so Gags, die auf der Strasse liegen. Wirklich? Na ja, meinst du wirklich, dass der eine, dass es als Gag gemeint ist von beiden? Wir können das beide nicht. Da braucht man eine Fähigkeit, Gags zu sehen, die auf der Strasse liegen und die zu ergreifen, am Schopf zu packen und rauszuhauen. Wir sind zu schnell unterwegs, wir sind zu schnell unterwegs auf dem Datenhighway, wir mer merken gar nicht, was daneben ansteht. Wir sind so ein Kaleidoskopartiger Podcast, der keine Zeit und keinen Platz und keine Farben dafür hat. Wir sind so ein bisschen wie aus dem Wilden Westen, diese Kurbelwägen. Kennst du diese Kurbelwägen, die auf Schienen stehen und wo dann zwei Leute so oben mit so einer großen Kurbel hoch und runter fahren können, wo ich mich immer gefragt habe, was ist das denn? Gab es die wirklich oder ist das so eine Art Gag-Modul? Nein, nein, ich glaube es gab es wirklich, aber es war halt eine blöde Erfindung. Ich glaube im Wilden Westen hatten die auch generell nicht so geile Erfindungen. Ich dachte, was du meinst, wenn du sagst, wir sind so wie im Wilden Westen, ich dachte, du meinst, wir sind diese Wüstenbälle, die so von Stadt zu Stadt, genau. Ist das eine gute Metapher für uns, die von Stadt zu Stadt rollen, genau wie wir. Wir rollen von Thema zu Thema, aber wir sind nicht wirklich beliebt, bei keinem Thema. Wir sind ja auch so ein bisschen Heldenfiguren, ne? Und jeder Helden fährt ja in seinem Heldentum, in seinem Abenteuer einen gewissen Prozess. Er fällt hin, er scheitert, er steht wieder auf, er findet Verbündete, dann betrügen ihn die Verbündeten wieder, dann muss er sein Ziel überdenken, ist sein Ziel eigentlich das, was er will, oder liegt das Ziel nicht viel mehr in ihm selbst, ist nicht er selber das Ziel und so weiter. Wie ist das Ziel, bitte sagen? Ich will sagen, dass wir uns gerade an einem ganz kritischen Punkt in dieser Heldenentwicklung befinden. Letzte Woche, beziehungsweise vor eineinhalb Jahren, Folge 5, war nicht gut. Das war ein Tiefpunkt. Das ist echt scheiße. Die Frage ist, kommen wir aus diesem Loch wieder raus? Ja. Wie geht die Geschichte weiter? Also jetzt, das ist das so der Cliffhanger. Ich glaube, so ein, zwei Folgen geben uns die Leute nicht. Der Cliffhanger ist, dass es total scheiße ist gerade. Er ist ein unglaublicher Abschalter. Ich habe noch mal zu einer Helden-Geschichte. Ich habe eben gerade einen super Tweet gelesen zu Superhelden. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es dir so wiedergeben kann, aber es wäre doch eine geniale Superkraft von Helden, wenn dem der Tod ihrer Eltern scheißegal wäre, oder? Alle Eltern von allen Superhelden sind tot und dann wärst du echt die beste Superhelden. Das ist ein sehr guter Tweet gewesen. Apropos Twitter. Aber das ist Teil des Ballastabwerfens. Es gibt in jeder Geschichte den Punkt, wo der Held den Ballast abwerfen muss, um sein Ziel erreichen zu können. Also willst du mich abwerfen? Das war eigentlich so ein bisschen der Hintergedanke. Aber das ist immer so der Punkt, wo der Held den Ballast abwerfen muss, um nach vorne zu kommen. Schön, dass du bei der Held mittlerweile bist, im Singular. Nicht gut. Ja, im metaphorischen Sinne sind wir ja zusammen ein Held. Naja, aber wir haben... Apropos Twitter, ich wollte mal kurz sagen, wo wir gerade eben bei Twitter schon waren, wir haben jetzt einen Twitter-Account namens Das Podcast UFO und da kann man uns jetzt erreichen und zwar twitter.com slash Das Podcast UFO zusammengeschrieben und da kann man uns jetzt schreiben, wir werden da sehr aktiv alles raushauen. Haben wir da schon einen blauen Haken eigentlich? Wir haben keinen blauen Haken. Achso, also hat niemand von uns einen blauen Haken. Und darum solltest du dich kümmern. Das ist das Erste, was du machen musst. Wenn der blaue Haken noch nicht ist, dann nimmt es doch keiner ernst als Podcast-Ufo. Also hat niemand von uns einen blauen Haken, oder? Du hast einen blauen Haken. Ah, ich habe auch einen blauen Haken. Der ist damit nicht weg. Nein. Ah, okay, dann habe ich ihn. Okay, gut, dann wollte ich nur. Es sei denn, die Folge ist sehr schlecht, dann könnte es sein, dass der Blauhaken dir entzogen wird. Ich glaube kaum, dass die Folge sehr schlecht wird, denn wir haben fantastische Themen hervorgerufen, wir haben gebrainstormt, bis unsere Köpfe qualmen, um fantastische Themen zu bekommen, und zwar heute das Thema der Folge Prüfen und Liefern. Geprüft bekommen und liefern geworden ist so ein bisschen das Unterthema.
Geliefert werden, selber geliefert werden, jemandem geliefert werden, ausgeliefert sein.
Denn das passt ja auch gerade so ein bisschen in die Heldenphase. Stefan wird ja gerade geprüft, ne, Trials, er muss gewisse Hürden überwinden, um weiterzukommen.
Wir sind alle geprüft, wir werden geprüft von diesem Medium an sich, weil wir an unsere Grenzen stoßen.
Würdest du sagen, das Leben ist eine Prüfung?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Und ich bin schon des Öfteren durchgerasselt, aber bis jetzt ist es noch weitergegangen. Ich werde ja im Moment tatsächlich geprüft, deswegen erscheinen wir auch so unregelmäßig, manchmal auch gar nicht einfach, aber wir sagen auch niemandem, es wundert auch glaube ich gar nicht so viele Leute, dass wir unregelmäßig erscheinen, weil wir es bis jetzt nie geschafft haben, regelmäßig zu erscheinen. Das stimmt aber gar nicht. Wir haben tatsächlich auf unserer Facebook-Seite Kommentar bekommen bekommen. Ich möchte mich sehr dafür bedanken. Ja, sehr nett. Ich muss ja leider immer wieder anmerken, dass es nicht meine Schuld ist tatsächlich, sondern dass es die Schuld von Stefan Tietze ist. Ja, das nehme ich auch voll auf mich. Aber wie gesagt, ich werde geprüft im Moment, Examen stehen an, zwei Klausuren muss ich schreiben, für die ich das ganze Semester noch nichts gemacht habe. Ich habe keine Vorlesung besucht, weil das dieses Jahr irgendwie nicht so wahr so sein musste.
Und deswegen kommt jetzt alles die ganze Arbeit auf mich zu und da muss man halt immer durch.
Aber bist du eher so der Typ, also es gibt ja zwei Anfragen von Prüfungen, es gibt ja die, so ich mal, offene Prüfungen, geschlossene Prüfungen.
Also eine geschlossene Prüfung ist, vier mal acht ist gleich.
Dann gibt es eine klare Antwort, die hat man oder hat man nicht.
Aber eine offene Prüfung, in der man irgendwie einen Aufsatz schreiben muss über, darf der Papst seine Kinder schlagen, ja oder nein.
Vielen Dank. mal acht ist gleich. Dann gibt es eine klare Antwort, die hat man oder hat man nicht. Eine offene Prüfung, in der man irgendwie einen Aufsatz schreiben muss über, darf der Papst seine Kinder schlagen, ja oder nein. Welcher bist du ja der Typ? Bist du ja so der Abgeschlossene, der so eine Antwort unten stehen hat und dann ist sie richtig oder bist du mehr so der Schwafler? Also ich würde, also wenn ich die Wahl hätte, würde ich immer die Schwafelklausel nehmen, natürlich. Die Schwafelklausel ist das Beste, was mir jemals passiert ist, die Erfindung der Schwafelklausel ist das Beste. Du kannst Punkte holen, indem du einfach Dinge begründest. Die Überschrift schreibst. Die Überschrift schreibst, das Datum schreibst, du kannst Dinge begründen. Ich habe Gedichtsanalysen geliebt, in einer Sprache habe ich die nur geschrieben meistens, aber ich habe sie geliebt. Das war der Hammer, du konntest einfach Dinge reininterpretieren in Wörter und meistens hat es auch einigermaßen Sinn ergibt, wenn du halt einigermaßen nachdenken kannst und so ein Mensch verstanden anwittest, dann kannst du in alle Dinge irgendwas rein interpretieren und das war dann immer ganz gut, aber bei geschlossenen Klauseln
muss man wirklich was dafür tun, weil da gibt es halt nur null oder eins, nur richtig oder falsch
und das ist halt dann ein bisschen blöd. Aber vor allem, ich meine, die Situation an sich in der
Prüfung ist ja teilweise viel wichtiger, als ob du die Antwort kennst oder nicht. Also wenn du in der
Prüfung denkst, du hättest keine Ahnung, ist es viel schlimmer, als wenn du wirklich keine Ahnung hast. Hattest du das mal? Und da sind natürlich... Hattest du mal eine richtig schlimme Klausel, wo du wirklich... Klar, natürlich, ständig. Wo du weinend vom Papier gewessen hast. Aber da sind ja geschlossene Prüfungen wesentlich schlimmer, weil vor allem, wenn man die Antwort einschätzen kann, also Physik oder sowas, wie heiss ist die Sonne, berechnet sie das und dann kommt daraus 80 Milliarden Grad, so, ja, kann hinhauen, keine Ahnung, ist vielleicht 18 Nullen weit von entfernt, aber kann schon stimmen. Aber ich erinnere mich an eine Klausur, auch Mathe, wo ich wirklich lachen musste während der Klausur und das ist immer so der Punkt, wo auch die anderen Schüler nervös werden, wenn jemand anfängt zu lachen, so, was, habe ich in Witz nicht verstanden. Das sind die Reaktionen. Es gibt zwei Reaktionen, die nicht erlaubt sind bei Prüfungen, wenn die anderen einem wichtig sind, einmal laut loslachen, einmal anfangen zu heulen und rausrennen, heulend rausrennen. Was ist da passiert? Und zwar war die Aufgabe relativ simpel, ein Heissluftballon steht hundert Meter weit von dir entfernt und dann fliegt er in die Luft und Und du hast dann so ein Gradmesser, den stellst du auf dem Boden und dann misst du irgendwie, wenn der dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung, so und so viel Meter in der Luft ist, misst du dann mit dem Gradmesser, wie viel Grad von dir aus der Winkel ist, um eine Linie zu ziehen von dir auf dem Boden zu dem Ballon in der Luft. Und dann musst du ausrechnen, du kennst die Entfernung von dir zu dem Punkt, an dem er gestartet ist, und du kennst den Winkel und rechnest es aus. Und irgendwie die Angaben waren Entfernung irgendwie 120 Meter, Winkel 60 Grad. Und ich rechne rum, weil es ja okay, Rechenweg erst das hier, das hat das Pythagoras, Sinus, Cosinus, durch drei hier mal zwölf und dann kam am Ende raus 1,6 Zentimeter. Und das ist so ein Ding, da da hältst du mal kurz inne in der Klasse und denkst, 1,6 cm, 120 Meter, 60 Grad, kann auch nicht so sein. Aber das Problem ist, du hast genau den Rechenweg benutzt, den du kennst und den du dachtest, den du vertraut hast, wo du dachtest, klar, mit dem komme ich ans Ziel, das ist wie so ein Boot, wo du dich gerne reinsetzt und sagst, klar, ich muss nur genug rudern und komme ans Ziel, aber dann kommst du ans Ziel mit 1,2 cm, vor allem 1,2 cm, dann denkst du ja, scheiße, da muss ich echt lachen, weil das Ergebnis so absurd war, aber was sollst du machen, sollst du dann schätzen, so 1,2, wahrscheinlich nicht, Herr Lehrer, sagen wir mal, naja, was wird sein, 200 Meter, dann kannst du das machen, du musst es abgeben, mit dem Wissen ist es falsch und das ist echt ganz unangenehm. Das ist aber auch, was du sagst, das sind so, bei Physik kann ich das immer, da kamen dann Antworten raus und ich wusste dann nicht, was ich damit anfangen sollte, dann meistens kam dann eine Formel wieder raus und es hätte die richtige Antwort sein können, ich hätte es nicht erkannt. Der Name des Physikers kommt raus. Ja, der Name des Physikers kommt raus. Beinstein? Ach, verdammt! Das kann ja nicht sein. Kann richtig sein? Weiß ich nicht. Du hast recht, es ist immer die Prüfungsituation ist entscheidend und wir hatten immer einen Lehrer, der war ein sehr netter, coole Kollege eigentlich, also war ein cooler Lehrer, ein sehr, sehr kompetenter Lehrer, aber war unglaublich nervig bei Klausuren, weil das war ein Kettenraucher und irgendwann fang er die Klausuren an, länger zu werden und er hat das nicht mehr so ausgehalten, war ein sehr nervöser Typ, war auch Schlagzeuger und hat immer angefangen, während der Prüfung auf seinem Tisch herumzukloppen und meinte dann immer, ja, okay, ich lasse es sein, hat er seinen Mac rausgeholt, weil er einfach so alle haben geschrieben, war total ruhig und dann hat er seinen Mac hochgefahren und alle erkennen dieses Geräusch, Dong, einfach mitten im Klassenraum. Und alle reißt es hoch. Alle, wow, was passiert, alle aus ihrer Konzentration gerissen. Das war das Gegenstück eines normalen Lehrers, wie er sich halt während der Klausur mal benommen war, das war ganz lustig. Er ist auch mal durch Klassenraum gelaufen, er hat rumgehüpft und so. Das ist dann auch scheiße eigentlich. Wobei es nimmt halt so ein bisschen diese Prüfungsseriosität, nimmst raus. Alle haben so ein Lachen auf den Lippen, auf der Stirn. Und das ist so ein bisschen auflockernd auch. Das braucht man auch bei Prüfungen. Aber ich meine, am interessantesten sind die Situation, in der du geprüft wirst und keine Ahnung hast. Also klassisches Ausfragen, du gehst vorne an die Tafel und hast überhaupt keinen Plan. Und dann bist du eigentlich in einer relativ freien Situation, weil du denkst, okay, die sechs habe ich sicher, alles was passieren kann, ich kann noch besser werden. Ich kann jetzt durch Improvisation, Sympathie, Charme, kann ich noch ein paar Punkte rausziehen und einfach ein paar Dinge richtig machen. Und aus den gegebenen Antworten des Lehrers kann ich irgendwer ableiten, was als nächstes kommt. Also wenn der Proton da aufschlägt, steigt dann die Energie oder sinkt die Energie?
Sie steigt, ja richtig, hey, grossartig.
Wo ich mir auch tatsächlich, das ist, also manche Geschichten sind so gut, die kann man eigentlich gar nicht erzählen, weil sie einem die Leute nicht glauben.
Und ich habe so eine Geschichte, also eine Wasserbildung ist natürlich ein guter Anfang für eine Story, aber die auch mit Prüfen zu tun hat.
Und zwar habe ich Abi gemacht in meinen Leistungskursen, Mathe und in Wirtschaft und Recht. Also eine Wasserbildung ist natürlich ein guter Anfang für eine Story, aber die auch mit Prüfen zu tun hat.
Und zwar habe ich Abi gemacht in meinen Leistungskursen Mathe und in Wirtschaft und Recht. Und da haben wir dann im Vorhinein lauter Textausschnitte bekommen, hier Seite 8 bis Seite 80, die wir lesen sollten. Und ich war dann am Tag da, der Prüfung, und dann habe ich mich so unterhalten über den Stoff. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich fest, dass ich dass die Seitenanzahl, die ich bekommen habe,
habe ich gelernt
und jemand hat mir gesagt so, ja
wir haben ja den Zettel bekommen mit den ganzen Seiten, die wir
nicht lernen sollten.
Bitte was?
Und dann habe ich tatsächlich komplett
falsch gelernt.
Ich habe nur das gelernt, was wir nicht hätten
lernen sollen. Das ist wirklich kein Witz.
Es ist kein Witz, da dachte ich mir auch,
da musste ich auch lachen. Aber du hast dich dann wahnsinnig gut ergänzt mit deinem... Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Ich habe genau das gelernt, was nicht abgefragt wurde. Aber dann war ich halt auch in der Klausur drin, mündlich, und dachte mir, gut, scheiss drauf. Mündlich ist ja nicht so schlecht, da kannst du die Fragen immer Martin-Sonneborn-mäßig, ja, sehr gute Frage, wir können auf eine andere Anspruch. Genau, ja, apropos Paragraf 80, was ich da noch so zu sagen wollte. Aber dann war tatsächlich die Frage, so Herr Will, wir haben ja gesprochen über Schadensersatz, stellen Sie sich vor, Sie gehen auf einen Bauernhof, nehmen dort ein Schwein, das Ihnen nicht gehört, laufen mit dem Schwein davon, jetzt auf dem Heimweg zieht ein Gewitter auf und das Schwein, das sie tragen, wird von einem Blitz getroffen und stirbt. Müssen sie Schadensersatz leisten?
Das ist die Absurde. Und dann sitzt du da und überlegst, ja, schon richtig.
Und du so, what, das war jetzt die Frage?
Und du so, ja, eigentlich schon, klingt fair.
Ja, richtig, nächste Frage.
Und ich so, what what ich habe eine frage geschafft ich glaube da war es dann das ist dann auch dabei geblieben aber das fand ich ganz gut dass die erste frage mit reinem menschenverstand zu beantworten war ja das ist nicht toll hat mir gut gefallen fand es du warst auch mündliche prüfungen immer besser als schriftliche ne ja total toll also fand ich fand ich gut mir immer gut gefallen. Ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass man mit seinen Blicken dann auch noch die Lehrer, die vor einem sitzen, beeinflussen kann. Aber weiß ich nicht, vielleicht auch nicht. Warst du jemand, der dann auch, wenn jemand an der Tafel stand und keine Ahnung hatte, dann auch reingerufen hat und versucht, dem zu helfen? Nee, nicht zu helfen, ihn noch mehr zu verunsichern. Das fand ich immer lustig. Ich habe immer laut losgelacht und immer, ey, Idiot! Ne, ich habe immer beschimpft. Ich finde es auch immer lustig, ich habe immer laut losgelacht und immer, ey Idiot! Ich habe immer beschimpft. Ich fände es auch immer lustig, also ich habe relativ früh erkannt, dass man sich nicht beliebt macht, also ich war immer einer, der sehr viel geredet hat. Und ich habe relativ früh gemerkt, dass man sich nicht mit dem Lehrer anlegen sollte, weil das hat dann Auswirkungen auf die Noten. Ich war ein sehr pragmatischer Typ, da habe ich relativ früh angefangen, mich mit dem Lehrer zu verbünden gegen andere Schüler. Gegen die anderen Schüler, ja. Ich war immer sehr beliebt. Nee, aber das war immer ganz lustig. Deswegen war es immer ganz lustig, wenn Leute an der Tafel standen und nichts wussten. Ich habe aber auch nie verstanden, warum die dann im Gegensatz zu dir dann auch meistens nichts gesagt haben, wenn sie nichts wussten. Weil du hast ja recht, man kann sich ja immer noch den Arsch retten, wenn man einfach irgendwas sagt. Genau wie man sich retten kann in Klausuren, wenn man nichts weist, dann einfach trotzdem was hinschreiben. Das ist der beste Trick einfach, weil dann kriegst du halt immer noch, wenn es gut ist, einen Punkt. Bei uns gab es so eine Abfragetechnik, da wurden zwei Schüler gleichzeitig an die Tafel geholt und wir hatten so eine aufklappbare Tafel und die wurde dann aufgeklappt. Also und so, dass der andere nicht sehen konnte, was der andere geschrieben hat. Genau, da mussten sich die Schüler dahinter stehen und dann gab es irgendwie Vokabelabfragen, glaube ich. Dann hat der Lehrer Vokabeln vorgelesen auf Französisch und dann musste man das deutsche Wort hinschreiben. Und die Situation war aber so, dass die Leute, die ausgefragt wurden, vom Lehrer nicht gesehen wurden, weil die Tafel dazwischen war, aber sie haben die anderen Schüler gesehen. Und das heißt, es gab die Situation, dass sie dann irgendwie gefragt hat, was heisst denn Chanson und alle gestikulieren mit den Händen, versuchen irgendwie irgendwo das Wort darzustellen und der andere schaut in der klassischen Charade-Manier in das Publikum und rufen, klauen, reden, schreibt irgendwas hin. Und das war dann auch tatsächlich immer sehr schön, weil es ein System war, das eigentlich Idioten sicher ist. Weil man kann völlig ohne Hemmnisse einsagen, aber es hat auch nicht viel gebracht. Das stimmt, aber Klassen sind oft so, dass sie den Leuten, also dass sie sich selber, Klassen sind zusammengenommen, denken sie, sie werden intelligent. Was eine Gemeinschaftsklasse, was eine Klassengemeinschaft macht, denkt man immer, weil... Was gefährlicher Trugschluss ist. Meistens ist es scheisse. Wir hatten ganz oft versucht, dass wir, wenn der Lehrer zu spät kam zur Prüfung, versucht haben, die ganzen Lösungen an die Tafel zu schreiben. Es hat nie funktioniert. Die wurden immer, hat der Lehrer das gemerkt, oder wenn die Lehrer zu spät kamen, vorm Raum, dass die ganze Klasse einfach weggegangen ist. So nach dem Motto, ja, bin ich begonnen. Hat aber auch nie funktioniert, weil es einfach Klassen, die Klassenintelligenz ist einfach scheisse.
Meistens liegen Klassen daneben, mit dem, was Sie sagen. Das stimmt, ja, das stimmt. Es gab eine Lehrerin bei uns, die hat auch nie klassisch abgefragt, sondern da musste man ein kurzes Referat halten darüber, was in der letzten Stunde tatsächlich gebracht wurde. Und ich weiss noch, die Situation war irgendwie anders. Auf jeden Fall wussten wir schon, dass wir ein Referat halten mussten. Ich und, nee, es war eine andere Situation. Ich habe die Situation vergessen. Ich weiss nur noch, dass die Situation ungefähr so war. Ein Depp, letzte Reihe, ja, ich und ein anderer Depp setzte in der letzten Reihe und wir müssen ein Referat halten, ich muss über Vorstellungsgespräche ein Referat halten und er über irgendwas anderes, komplett dämliches Thema. Und dann, ja, drei Leute sollten ein Referat halten und ja, während der erste ein Referat hält, gehen die anderen beiden mal bitte vor die Tür und warten. Und dann stehen wir da draußen vor der Tür und denken ernsthaft darüber nach, ob wir jetzt einfach weglaufen sollen, ob wir einfach fliegen sollen. Und dann geht die Tür auf und ah, Florentin, ah, weg, na ja, gut. Und dann war es auch so ein klassisches Halbmaterialverrat über Vorstellungsgespräche. Ja, wichtig ist es, dass man sehr selbstbewusst ist und sich über die Firma informiert davor und halt einfach nur Müll aus dem Arsch gezogen und einfach völlig nichtssagend irgendwas erzählt, aber trotzdem, nochmal drei plus. Ist auch gut zu sagen, aber das sind auch wieder so Laberklauze, wo man dann sagen kann, was man bei Vorstellungsgesprächen nicht machen sollte, weil so eine Riesenliste aufsehen kann, ja man sollte nicht nackter erscheinen, man sollte nicht besoffen erscheinen und dann kannst du halt sehr viel sagen, auch ausser La Meng, wie der Kölner sagt, ausser La Meng. Apropos Köln, wie sieht es eigentlich bei dir aus mit Karneval? Ist das kompatibel oder bist du da allergisch? Nee, ich habe in Köln noch nie Karneval gefeiert. Ich wohne jetzt hier, weiß ich gar nicht wie lange, eineinhalb Jahre oder so. Du bist doch ein lustiger Typ. Du bist doch für den Jux aufgelegt. Karneval ist für mich nichts, glaube ich. Ich bin versucht dann immer in dem Kostüm zu bleiben. Also ich war zum Beispiel in Halloween Du nimmst die Rolle zu ernst. Ja, ich war Batman. Hast dann Leute gerettet. Genau, hier würde ich dann teilweise behaupten, ich wäre Bruce Wayne. Was Batman hier machen würde. Ist mir aufgefallen, genau, genau. Ich war der schlechteste Batman aller Zeiten. Und das zieht mich dann immer so ein bisschen runter. Ich will dann immer die Figur sein, aber ich scheitere dann immer dabei, die Figur zu sein, darzustellen richtig und dann macht es mir traurig.
Ich hatte als Kind immer so furchtbar schlechte Kostüme, dass niemand erkannt hatte, was ich war.
Und einmal war ich irgendwie als Harry Potter verkleidet und hatte irgendwie eine alte Fussmatte als Umhang irgendwie um und irgendwie so einen komischen durchsichtigen Stift als Zauberstab.
Hat dann irgendwie jemand gefragt, was sollst du denn sein? Und dann habe ich immer gesagt, ja, irgendwas aus so einem Star-Wars-Roman, das kennst du nicht, das ist was total Spezielles, obwohl ich Harry Potter sein wollte, was jeder kannte. Aber ich habe dann gesagt, nee, das weisst du, das kennst du gar nicht, aber ich habe es total gut getroffen. Aber es fällt einem immer noch auf, wenn man versucht, derjenige zu sein, den man darstellt, dann fällt einem relativ schnell auf, dass man das auch nicht kann, weil so ein Batman wird selten beim Essen gezeigt zum Beispiel. Und wenn du dann abends irgendwie dann was isst als Batman und denkst, wie benimmst du dich denn jetzt? Wie isst Batman? Das ist eine gute Frage, das ist eine schöne Charakterstudie eigentlich. Oder Batman beim Smalltalk. Er hat immer dieses Tiefe und die Leute gucken zu ihm herauf und sagen, ja, I'm Batman. Das ist eigentlich das, was er am meisten öfters sagt. Ja genau, er sagt einen coolen Satz, wenn wir die andere Person antworten, dann ist er schon weg. Aber was würde er tun, wenn er nicht weg wäre? Wie würde er antworten? Da bin ich immer gescheitert, weil ich irgendwo hängen geblieben bin. Ja und sonst so Batman? Schnitt, er ist immer noch da und hängt irgendwie so am Stuhl dran dran. Ja, genau, wenn man einen Smalltalk macht, hat man einfach verloren.
Beziehungsweise als Kind, wenn man egal welches Kostüm man hatte, man sah einfach aus wie ein wandelnder Anorak, weil man musste egal welches Kostüm man hatte, noch einen Anorak drüberziehen und dann war es eh egal, was man war. Es ist immer zu kalt, es ist immer zu kalt. Eigentlich sollte Karneval auch im Sommer stattfinden, finde ich.
Stimmt.
Wie sind wir jetzt auf Karneval gekommen?
Ja, wie Köln, weil du so hier in Köl bisschen up to date? So ein bisschen losgeschnattert lassen. Aus der Lameng. Wenn man Kölner, also wenn ich ein Kölner Akzent nahmache, bin ich ein wahnsinnig schlechter Imitator. Ich bin ein wahnsinnig schlechter Imitator, aber wenn ich Kölner Akzent nahmache, habe ich immer so dieses , da habe ich immer so dieses , da ist auch dein Dendemann, oder? Kannst du mal Dendemann an Köln gegenüberstehen? Es ist wahnsinnig, es ist alles gleich. Ist bei mir auch Klaus Deva würde so klingen. Es ist ausser La Meng und Dendemann ist eigentlich auch Dendemann hat die Jacks am Start. Ist eigentlich sehr deckungsgleich. Aber es sind kleine Finessen, Impressionen, die kommen immer auf so ganz kleine Details an. Und da könnt ihr euch ja jetzt, könnt ihr mal auf 15 Sekunden zurück, kann man bei iTunes machen, dann könnt ihr euch anhören, wo der Unterschied war.
Ja stimmt, das habe ich auch tatsächlich lange nicht, ich bin jemand, ich benutze Technologien lange, bevor ich sie verstanden habe.
Und so zum Beispiel auch MP3 habe ich oft gehört, Podcasts schon früh und habe zum Beispiel nie gerafft, dass es die Funktion gibt, dass man auch Podcasts mit halber, anderthalbfacher und doppelter Geschwindigkeit ablaufen lassen kann. Und dann kann man das auch noch ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so ein bisschen mehr so zufällig auf diesen Knopf gekommen, ohne es zu merken. Und dann hat er so schnell gesprochen und ich dachte mir, was ist denn jetzt hier los? Bin ich in einem Zeitstrudel gefangen, läuft um mich rum alles schneller ab, muss ich jetzt auch schneller laufen?
Laufen die Leute normal schneller um mich herum?
Was ist los? Ich war im Wald, ich war völlig alleine. Ich habe geguckt, so irgendwo ein Vogel bleibt in der Luft stehen. Was passiert gerade mit mir? Ich weiss es nicht. Und man würde es ja auch nicht merken, wenn man in den Zeitstrudel gerät. Man kann ja schlecht darüber kommunizieren, weil die anderen merken es nicht. Warum gehst du durch Wälder, Podcast hören durch Wälder? Mein Gott, mal einen schönen Spaziergang, mach ein bisschen die Natur, geniesst mal ein bisschen raus aus dem Haus und einen schönen Podcast hören über den Weltraum oder sowas. Aber ich glaube, für uns ist, ich glaube auch manchmal, dass manche Erfindungen ein bisschen zu früh kamen, bevor man sie eigentlich braucht. Die Technologie ist so schnell, man kommt nicht hinterher. Weil wir zum Beispiel, ich glaube, für uns macht es echt Sinn, das auf halber Geschwindigkeit zu kommen, weil wir so schnell reden. Das macht wirklich Sinn, aber ich kenne nicht viele andere Podcasts, wo die so schnell reden und so schnell von Thema zu Thema springen, dass diese Funktion Sinn macht. Genau wie diese 15 Sekunden nach vorne und zurückspringen, wo ich mich frage, warum 15, welche diese guten Zahl eigentlich gekommen? Warum nicht 20 Sekunden? Ich hatte tatsächlich mal eine Phase, wo ich so viele Podcasts hören wollte, dass ich mir echt dachte, wenn ich die jetzt in Echtzeit anhöre, wird das nichts. Dann hat man dann tatsächlich, glaube ich, auch so ein paar Folgen in eineinhalbfacher Geschwindigkeit angehört. Und man kommt da schon rein, irgendwann gewöhnt man sich dran, aber es hat trotzdem irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl irgendwie. So was Krankes. Hört uns jemand in doppler Geschwindigkeit? Ja, gute Frage. Macht doch jetzt mal, schau doch jetzt mal auf. Und versteht man dann alles darüber? Könnt ihr uns noch bitte bei Twitter schreiben, at das Podcast UFO, ob ihr uns in betäubelter Geschwindigkeit hört. Unser Hashtag ist Hashtag D für das Podcast UFO. Bitte alle Tweets zur Folge unter Hashtag D. Aber tatsächlich, warst du schon mal in einem Zeitstrudel gefangen? Ja, ich auch. Wann Wann das erste Mal? Gefühlt immer, als ich bei mir im Rathaus irgendwie, wo man sich dann einen Zettel zieht und dann darauf wartet, bis man dann irgendwie seinen Führer schon abholen kann oder so. Das waren so diese Momente, wo ich dachte, ich bin jetzt in einem Zeitstrudel gefangen, weil auch die Leute sich um mich herum nicht bewegt haben. Ja, tatsächlich stimmt. Im Nachhinein hat sich herausgestellt, das waren gar keine Leute, das waren Prospekte,
das waren nur abgedruckte Menschen auf irgendwelchen
Flyern. Und ich dachte, warum
die hat immer den Mund offen, aber die redet nicht,
was ist hier los? Und warum sehen die so
2D-mäßig aus? Was ich mir letztens dachte,
Zeit ist ja
relativ in gewisser Weise,
weil man, also
Zeit spielt sich ja auch in deinem Gehirn ab,
manche Dinge laufen schneller ab und manche
langsamer ab, in gewisser Weise,
beziehungsweise der subjektive Eindruck von Zeit ist ja
Vielen Dank. Weil, also Zeit spielt sich ja auch in deinem Gehirn ab. Manche Dinge laufen schneller ab und manche langsamer ab, in gewisser Weise. Beziehungsweise der subjektive Eindruck von Zeit ist ja unterschiedlich. Jetzt dachte ich mir... Ich habe neulich... Kennst du den Film Lucy gefällt? Ne, habe ich nicht geguckt. Der ist wahnsinnig bedeutungsschwanger, glaubt der Film zu sein, und am Ende kommt so was wie, ja, was ist der Sinn des Lebens? Ja, Zeit. Zeit hält alles zusammen und ohne Zeit wüssten wir gar nicht, dass wir existieren. Und das ist so dämlich. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das ist, aber im Gehirn gibt es ja lauter so elektrische Ladungen, die durch die Gegend flitzen. Und angenommen, man würde jetzt sterben, dann ist es ja oft nicht so, dass die Gehirnaktivität von einer Sekunde auf die nächste sofort aufhört, sondern die fährt ja langsam runter.
Also du stirbst meinetwegen an Blutverlust oder was auch immer und das Gehirn kriegt nicht genug Nährstoffe oder wird nicht mit Sauerstoff versorgt.
Und dann ist es ja nicht sofort aus, so ach komm Kinder lassen wir, sondern es fährt langsam runter.
Das heißt, auch dein subjektives Zeitempfinden müsste dich wahrscheinlich verlangsamen,
weil diese elektrischen Strömegeschichten nicht mehr so schnell fliessen oder die Synapsen nicht mehr so schnell feuern oder was genau auch immer der richtige Ausdruck ist. Aber es verlangsamt sich alles. Deswegen meine Theorie ist es, wenn du stirbst, denkst du, die Zeit würde langsamer werden und irgendwann, wenn dein Gehirn nur noch auf ein Prozent Aktivität ist, muss es sich für dich ja unglaublich lange anfühlen. Das fühlt sich an … Das ist die pessimistischste Weltsicht, dass du den Moment am längsten wahrnimmst, der am furchtbarsten in deinem Leben ist, weil es endet. Stell dir mal vor, du siehst so ein Jahr lang, siehst du, gefühlt ein Jahr lang siehst du wie jemand mit einer Axt auf dich einstellt. Ja, absolut, aber eigentlich, also der letzte Gedanke, den du hast, ist ja dann für dich subjektiv extrem lang und du vielleicht in deiner Wahrnehmung fühlt sich das an wie Jahre und Jahrzehnte, weil dein Gehirn einfach kaum noch aktiv ist, aber du das ja noch mitkriegst so halb und dann irgendwann ist es halt aus, weil es ja halt so langsam runterfährt und du kriegst diesen Prozess ja auch mit. Das ändert natürlich auch meinen Wunsch, wie ich sterben möchte jetzt total. Achso, ja.
Weil, angenommen man verbrennt lebend, dann ist es ja wahrscheinlich, dass das Gehirn verkohlt, bevor wirklich diese Synapsen auf einmal langsamer funktionieren. Ja, das kommt ein bisschen darauf an, ob du an der Raufvergiftung stirbst oder ob du wirklich verbrennst. Was ist der beste Tod demnach? Verbrennen ist schon Top 3. Verbrennen ist definitiv eine Top 3, dann kommt Erfrieren, dann kommt lange nichts und dann kommt Ertrinken. Weil ich glaube, das ist ganz angenehm, Ertrinken eigentlich. Aber wo Ertrinken? Ich wäre gestern fast ertrunken. Ich wäre fast verblutet. Ich hätte tatsächlich so einen Waterboarding-Moment, weil ich bin gestern wieder nach Köln gefahren und da bin ich immer sehr müde, weil ich sehr früh hinfahre und versuche dann noch ein paar Stunden im Zug zu schlafen. Und wenn ich dann in Köln ankomme, bin ich komplett fertig, also Gehirnaktivität auch nur auf fünf Prozent. Es fühlt sich an wie acht Jahre in diesem Zug. Und dann habe ich meine Wasserflasche bis zum Rand komplett oben gefüllt mit Wasser, wie ich immer Wasser zu Hause habe. Und dann habe ich diese Schlaftröken rausgenommen, geöffnet, wollte sie gerade so hoch stemmen und habe sie so unter mich gehalten und hat der zug so einen ruck gemacht und habe ich auf diese flasche draufgedrückt und dann ist mir eine fontäne wasser direkt in die nase hochgeschossen in mein gesicht meine komplette pullover war nass also wenn das jemand gesehen hat wie ich mich da gerade selbst fast eliminiert hätte und fast sich mich selbst ertrunken hätte in einem ICE das war glaube ich schon ein schönerner Anblick. Muss ich auch laut lachen tatsächlich. Darf man als Fast-Promi aber nicht machen eigentlich, ne? Sonst kommen dann die ganzen Anrufe wie, boah, ich war gerade mit Florentin Will im Zug und er ist fast ertrunken, Idiot! Aber das ist der Vorteil, das glaubt dir niemand. Wenn du erzählt hättest, ey, das war so ein fetter hässlicher Typ neben mir, der hat sich komplett vollgespritzt, okay, aber das, was Florentin Will, das glaubt dir niemand. Niemand glaubt er. Du bist auch echt, du wurdest jetzt zweimal karikiert, ich habe zwei Karikaturen von dir gesehen. Sehr schmeichelhaft getroffen tatsächlich. Du bist auf einer Ebene mit Mohammed war hier. Das stimmt, ja, absolut. Ich nehme vor, wegen dir werden irgendwann auch Kriege geführt, wegen den Menschen werden Leute umgebracht. Du hast jetzt so eine Verantwortung und auch der Podcast wird damit ein bisschen bedeutungsschwerer jetzt. Du musst aufpassen.
Komm, soll ich meine Anecdote raushauen? Es passt gerade sehr gut, wenn wir gerade bei Promis in Zügen sind, weil ich habe nämlich einen Promi in einem Zug getroffen.
Als ich nämlich vorletzte Woche wieder zurückgefahren bin von Köln nach Berlin, war es so, ich habe immer eine Reservierung und wenn man in einen Zug kommt, der schon von weiter entfernt kommt, ist es ja so, dass da schon Leute drin sitzen und dann kommt man rein und dann ist oft die Situation, gerade wenn die Deutsche Bahn, möchte ich jetzt mal in Anführungszeichen setzen, Deutsche Bahn, ja, gerade irgendwie verpeilt hat, die Reservierungen anzeigen zu lassen, dann ist es oft so, dass Leute auf deinem Platz sitzen und dann musst du die verscheuchen. So, jetzt sitzt du aber nicht irgendeinem, natürlich, klar. Entschuldigung, Sie sitzt auf meinem Platz, das ganze Abteil ist frei, aber ich stehe auf meinem Platz.
Nein, Stefan, da möchte ich jetzt mal kurz einhaken, das hat nichts mit Pedanterie zu tun, weil mein Gedankenexperiment ist mal folgendes, okay, da sitzt jetzt meinetwegen Hugo Egon Balder auf meinem Platz, dann sage ich, okay, gut, dann setze ich mich halt da hinten hin, neben Heller von Sinn, ja, kein Problem, aber was ist dann die Person, was ist dann, wie beschränkt dein Kosmos ist, dass war kurz davor, wie kein Boging zu sagen, und da war ich mir nicht sicher, ob es Wienerl Boging oder Bernhard Holger war, ob ich die nicht verwechsel. Aber auf jeden Fall, was ist dann, wenn die Person kommt, die auf dem Platz sitzen wollte, auf dem ich sitze, dann neu, dann muss ich weg und dann ist es eine Kettenreaktion. Und deswegen, um diese Kettenreaktion von Anfang an zu unterbinden, schicke ich einfach die Person weg, die auf meinem Platz sitzt und dann ist alles gut.
Dann bin ich nicht mehr in dieser Kettenreaktion verwickelt. Auf jeden Fall saß auf meinem Platz eine berühmte Person.
So, wer war es?
Ja, wer war es? Das ist die Frage.
Adolf Hitler.
Fast, fast tatsächlich. Nein, also die Frage, eine Person, die man jetzt sage ich mal auf einer im ICE vielleicht sogar erwarten würde.
Harald Schmidt. Nein, Harald Schmidt fährt glaube ich nicht ICE. Doch. Also ich sag mal, Eckart von Hirschhausen war es ein Moderator, ein Mann und eine
Frau.
Eckart von Hirschhausen war es ein Moderator, ein Mann und eine Frau.
Eckart von Hirschhausen ist extrem nah, extrem nah.
Ich sag nur ...
Wir machen dieses Spiel, als ob ich diesen Mann auf der Stirn klebe.
Ja, okay, okay. Wer bin ich?
Genau, bin ich ein Mann?
Ja, wahrscheinlich jetzt.
Bin ich fast Eckart von Hirschhausen?
Yes!
Moderiere ich eine Show im Fernsehen?
Obwohl das auch irreführend sein könnte, weil die Sendung nicht sehr bekannt ist. Aber ja.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich das Schlechteste.
Bin ich eine Frau?
Nein, bin ich ein Ausländer oder bin ich deutsch? Du bist kein Ausländer. Jetzt bist du dran. Keine Ahnung. Wofür ist denn Eckart von Hirschhausen bekannt? Ja, für wahnsinnig viel. Für welche Medien? So, ja, so öffentlich-rechtliches Geplänkel. Nein, also für welche Form der Ausdrucksart. Aha, Buch, genau, sehr gut. Buch sind wir sehr, sehr nah dran. Charlotte Roche. Mann, wie gesagt, wir sind an einer Person aus dem literarischen Werk. Falls Sie jetzt erst einschalten, wir spielen seit drei Stunden. Nein, ich sage dir einfach, wer es ist, und zwar habe ich es auch nicht direkt gemerkt. Ich steige ein, laufe durch die Gänge, grimmige Figuren, gucke mich an, ich gucke die Reservierungsplätze an und dann, ah, da sitzt jemand auf meinem Platz, wer ist es denn?
Ich gucke runter und sehe tatsächlich ein relativ lässig in sich zusammengeschmolzenes Wesen, das halb lungert, irgendwie die Füsse so halb hochgelegt, so gegen das Fenster gewandt, die Haare ins Gesicht ein bisschen verstrusselt, relativ unspektakuläre Kleidung, sitzt er vor mir, Richard David Precht. Ach, und? Er hat mit ihm geredet. Und ich habe ihn nicht sofort erkannt, tatsächlich. Ich habe angefangen, weil ich relativ routiniert bin, so hier, weg da,
ich sitze da, relativ routiniert,
habe ich gesagt, Entschuldigung, ich habe hier
reserviert und dann guckt er mich verschlafen an,
steht auf und er denkt mir, ach du Scheiße,
das ist Richard David Precht,
genau auf meinem Platz saß Richard David
Precht, sitzt er sich direkt auf eine andere,
auch so ein bisschen mit so einem,
man interpretiert da natürlich immer viel rein,
aber mit so einem, musste das jetzt sein, Blick, ich habe mich so schlecht gefühlt, weil es ist, Leute, ihr da draußen, ihr kennt es vielleicht nicht, aber es gibt nichts Schlimmeres, als einem Promi schlechtere Laune zu bereiten, wirklich, viele von euch können es nicht nachvollziehen, weil sie denken, ah, okay, hier, Leute interessieren mich aber nicht, aber einen Promi unglücklich machen, das ist ein Downer, das ist ein richtiger Downer. Und dann habe ich nochmal extra höflich ihn nochmal angelegt und gesagt, vielen Dank, Dankeschön, sehr freundlich. Und dann hat er auch lächelnd zurückgenickt und dann habe ich mich hingesetzt und dann ist er halt also gleich wieder eingenickt und dann fand ich toll. Und dann habe ich mich natürlich auch überlegt, was hätte man da sagen können, ne? Also haben Sie hier reserviert und wenn ja, wie viele? Ja, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Wo ich mir auch die Frage stelle, soll man das irgendwie ansprechen? Weil ich weiss gar nicht, also ich kann es relativ schlecht nachvollziehen, weil ich jetzt nicht so berühmt bin, ob es Promis lieber ist, wenn sie als Prominente angesprochen werden, als wenn die Leute, mit denen sie sprechen, so tun, als wüssten sie nicht, wer das ist. Verstehst du, was ich meine? Ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen wie mit Behinderten. Promis wollen, dass man sie behandelt wie normale Menschen. Oder auch nicht. Oder habe ich das falsch verstanden? Oder wollen Promis... Moment mal, was heißt denn normale Menschen? Für einen Behinderten ist es normal, so behandelt zu werden, wie ein behinderter Mensch. Und für einen Promi ist es normal, so behandelt zu werden wie ein Promi. Also was ist denn normal?
Ja, man sollte, genau, was ist normal? Das ist wie wenn du sagst, Frauen sollen normal behandelt werden, dann ist es ja auch was anderes. Also dann sagst du ja auch, sie sollen nicht so behandelt, normal für eine Frau bedeutet, so behandelt zu werden, wie eine Frau behandelt wird, wie man eine Frau behandeln würde. Also was ist normal? Also es ist es fairer, wenn du jeden Menschen gleich behandelst oder ob du sagst, ich behandle einen behinderten Menschen anders als einen Mann oder eine Frau oder einen Promi.
Und ich behandle einen Richard David Brecht wie ein Arschloch.
Ja, genau. Aber also, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass es für einen Promi unangenehm ist, wenn Leute immer so tun, als würden sie sie nicht kennen.
Und dann so heimlich angucken und dann so fotografieren mit dem iPhone und sowas, anstatt einfach zu sagen, ah, Herr Precht, schön, ich mag Ihre Bücher, toll, schöne Reise noch, ja, ist ihm vielleicht lieber, als wenn man so rumdrucksen
würde und ha ha ha, ja, Reservierung, ein unordentliches Gefühl, ich weiss nicht, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall habe ich mich total schlecht gefühlt und ich wusste nicht, wie ich damit umgehen soll und ich dachte mir mir, weil er hat ja auch Bücher geschrieben über Moral und so und Ethik und so. Und da dachte ich mir, soll ich jetzt so ein Gespräch mit ihm anfangen, weil ich finde ihn ja einen total interessanten Typen. Wo ich dann so fragen soll, ah, habe ich mich jetzt moralisch richtig verhalten, haaa oder so. Also was, das weiss ich nicht, aber er wollte offensichtlich nicht gestört werden und es war völlig falsch. Aber es war, ja, irgendwo schon. Irgendwo habe ich eswo habe ich es dann schon richtig gemacht. Es war eine Prüfung des Lebens und du hast sie bestanden, um noch kurz zum Thema zurückzukommen. Ja, sie wurde mir auf einem silbernen Tablett geliefert. Wir haben ja noch andere Themen. Wir haben ja noch auch das Thema Lieferung. Ja, ein Wunschthema von dir tatsächlich. Ja, genau. So aus dem Grund, dass ich neulich eine sehr merkwürdige Situation erlebt habe. Ich habe ja, wie gesagt, hier teilweise so einen Lerntag mal eingelegt, wo ich mich eingeschlossen habe und was dafür getan habe für die Uni. Und dann hatte ich auch Hunger halt und habe mir dann bei Pizza.de was bestellt. Pizza.de, das ist ja auch hier unsere Funktion als Podcast, Ratgeber-Podcast, liefert nicht nur Pizza, sondern man kann da auch andere Sachen bestellen.
Das war für mich irre, zu erkennen, dass Pizza.de nicht nur Pizzas liefert, sondern auch zum Beispiel chinesisch und indisch und weiß nicht was.
Und dann habe ich halt chinesisch da bestellt und habe dann gewartet, dann kam der auch, dann hat es irgendwann geklingelt, ich bin zur Tür gegangen und dann mache ich die Tür auf und steht da so ein sehr grimmig reinguckender Schrank, so südländischer Typ, Tattoos und so, schief vor der Tür, begrüsst mich auch gar nicht, hat nur meine Mini-Frühlingsrollen in der Hand und sagt dann sowas wie, du hast das letzte Mal nur drei Sterne gegeben. Wirklich? Du hast das letzte Mal nur drei Sterne gegeben. Und ich wusste gar nicht, wie soll ich da jetzt darauf reagieren? Also das war eine ganz, ganz komische Situation. Ja, aber stimmt das denn? Ja, genau. Es stimmte, ich habe den, das ist mir auch eingefallen, ich habe den, anscheinend war das Essen nicht so gut damals. Aber das kann ich mir nicht sagen, ich kann dir nicht sagen, hör mal, anscheinend war das Essen damals scheiße, weil ich habe ja offensichtlich schon wieder da bestellt. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, wir sind wegen dir einen Platz nach unten gerutscht in in dieser Rangliste. Und dann haben wir gesagt, ja, weiß ich auch nicht. Dann habe ich da angefangen nachzudenken, wer hat jetzt eigentlich gerade die Hosen an? Habe ich nicht gerade bei dem bestellt, bin ich nicht sein Kunde? Und dann habe ich irgendwie sowas gesagt wie, ja, da war ein Kumpel da und dem hat das nicht so geschmeckt. Nein, du bist so schlecht. Was soll man denn da machen? Du kannst doch nicht sagen, ich ... Kumpel ausweichen.
Genau, das ist wieder der Arschlochkumpel,
von dem man alles abwälzt.
Aber den hatten wir auch mal gesprochen.
Genau, das letzte Folge, glaube ich,
die gefühlten Jaher ist.
Aber du kannst dir dann nicht anfangen zu sagen,
ja, das Essen war anscheinend scheiße, weil du hast ja wieder da bestellt.
Und dann, ich war da so ein bisschen geschockt,
war auch froh, dass das Gespräch relativ schnell vorbei war. Aber du kannst dir so etwas sagen wie, ja, die Lieferleute sind immer so unfreundlich. Booyah! Ja, genau, das sagst du dann aber nicht. Und dann habe ich nämlich die Tür zugemacht und da hat er mir so, boah. Ja, aber ist das so eine Einschitterungsstrategie? Also bauen die darauf, dass es dann keine schlechten Bewertungen mehr gibt? Ja, genau. Genau, haben sie gesagt, ja, hat er gesagt, auch, ja, jetzt gib uns gefälligst was anderes. Und dann hat er nicht gesagt, aber habe ich in seinen Augen gelesen. Und dann habe ich die Tür zugemacht und dann habe ich so gedacht, ja, Gott sei Dank, es ist vorbei. Und dann macht er das Essen auf und es war wirklich, es war original das falsche Essen. Nein! Der Stand vor der Tür hat mich angemacht, als ich nur drei Sterne gegeben habe und grunnt mir das falsche Essen. Aber das ist eine Prüfung. Nein, nein, nein, nein, das ist kalkuliert. Das ist hundertprozentig kalkuliert. Das würde ich auch machen.
Und jetzt habe ich ihm wieder drei Sterne gegeben.
Du legst es aber auch drauf an, du bist ein ganz harter.
Es war lecker, es war lecker, aber es war halt falsch lecker. Es hat falsch geschmeckt.
Genau. Naja, und dann frage ich mich wirklich, wer hat jetzt noch in dieser Zeit, wo man Sachen liefern kann und Leute bewerten kann, die Hosen an, wenn jemand vor der Tür steht und sagt, du hast uns nur drei Stände gegeben und die haben ja dann Essen. Und Essen ist ja auch was, wo man dann dem, der das macht, vertrauen muss, dass er jetzt nicht reingerotzt wurde, dass da kein Gift drin ist. Also ich finde es... Wer hat dann noch die Hosen? Also ich sage ja immer, man hat als Kunde in gewisser Weise nicht die Verpflichtung, aber ich sage mal, es gehört sich, den Anbietern Rückmeldungen darüber zu geben, warum man aufhört, seine Dienste zu nutzen. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein Magazin deabonnierst aus einem ganz bestimmten Grund. Hast du da jemals einen richtigen Grund angegeben? Naja, also ich meine, es gab ja immer die die Rechtschreibreform und ich weiss nicht, ob in Bayern oder generell, also gab es dann einige Zeitschriften, die diese Rechtschreibreform nicht angenommen haben, die einfach weiter ihre Sachen in der alten Rechtschreibung gedruckt haben. Und mein Vater hat dann, ich glaube, die hört zu oder den Gong oder irgendwie so eine Zeitschrift, deabonniert und hat dann einen Brief hingeschrieben, ja, ich deabonniere sie, weil ich nicht möchte, dass sie diese Rechtschreibung nicht einführen. Ich will, dass sie diese auch einführen. Und das finde ich tatsächlich sehr gut, weil ich finde, das gehört auch dazu, dass es mal eine Rückmeldung gibt, warum man auch für den Dienst zu nutzen. Zum Beispiel, wenn einer unserer Podcast-Hörer jetzt ab dieser Folge keine Lust mehr hat, uns zu hören, finde ich, ist er dazu verpflichtet, uns zu schreiben, warum, damit wir darauf reagieren können, weil sonst sind wir ja komplett im Dunkeln. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man diese Verpflichtung akzeptiert, finde ich, hat man als Kunde auch in gewisser Weise die Verpflichtung, wenn man nur noch einen Stern gibt, dass man dann dann nicht mehr bestellt und wieder einen Stern gibt, weil dann ist man ja selber schuld, da kann man ja nichts dafür, man kann ja nicht dann wieder den Dienst nutzen, wissentlich, dass er in die Marken wieder einen Stern geben, weil da kann ja auch der Anbieter auch nichts dafür, weil der Deal ist, wenn es dir nicht schmeckt, ist woanders, es gibt genug Alternative. Also ich kann schon in gewisser Weise verstehen, wo auf der Herr hinausreite. Ich auch, ich auch, aber das war halt so eine ganz blöde Situation, weil man auch nicht weiß, ich habe auch nicht mehr daran gedacht, dass man da bestellt hat, weil es gibt ja in Köln ja auch nicht nur einen Chinesen und dann habe ich offensichtlich wieder da bestellt und naja, was macht man dann? Aber ich glaube, es war richtig, irgendwie wieder den Arschlochkumpel hinzuzusehen. Das war auf jeden Fall richtig, da stimme ich dir zu, aber die Frage ist, wie gehst du weiter damit um? Kann man häufiger bei einem Dienst bestellen, den man eigentlich nicht mag und ihm weiter schlechte Bewertungen gibt?
Ich habe mir jetzt den Namen aufgeschrieben und werde er dann nicht mehr bestellen. Aber ich finde, wenn du nochmal bestellst, wenn du den Dienst wieder einforderst, dann müsste es mehr als drei Sterne sein. Per Definition können es dann keine drei Sterne mehr sein. Selbst wenn du das falsche Essen bekommen hast, wenn du mit dem Dienst so zufrieden warst, dass du ihn wieder nutzt, können es keine drei Sterne mehr sein. Das ist irgendwo ein innerer Widerspruch. Es gibt ja auch Tage, an denen man mit drei Sterne mal zufrieden ist, wo man jetzt sagt, ich will keinen fünf Sterne essen, das ist mir heute zu viel. Was heisst mit drei Sternen zufrieden? Die Sterne sind ein Ausdruck deiner Zufriedenheit. Du kannst nicht sagen, ich bin auch mal mit einem Stern zufrieden, weil das wäre nicht zufrieden. So funktioniert das System, Stefan. Drei Sterne ist für mich befriedigend. Das ist okay. Wir reden schon von fünf, oder? Aber gibt es insgesamt sechs Wertungen oder fünf? Also gibt es auch null Sterne oder gibt es nur einen? Nee, ich habe insgesamt nur einen. Also eins ist selten. Also eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, also fünf Wertungen. Okay. Ja, in meinem System ist drei trotzdem noch befriedigend. Es war okay, es war okay, das war nicht schlecht und vielleicht gibt es ja auch keine anderen Chinesen. Nein, aber ich finde, wenn du jetzt ein drittes Mal bestellst, musst du mindestens vier Sterne aufwärts geben. Das funktioniert nicht. Dieses Restaurant ist auf meiner Blacklist, weil ich habe auch ebendlich Angst. Ich habe Angst um mein Leben, wenn da wieder der Typ vor meiner Tür steht, mit mehreren chinesischen Verkäufern und dann keine Ahnung, so liniamässig, dass sie mein Haus irgendwie ... Bezahlst du in den Bar vor Ort oder bezahlst du mit PayPal? Das ist auch so ein Ding. Ich habe mit PayPal bezahlt. Ja, und wie ist das mit Trinkgeld? Genau, das ist aber nicht, ist es gesellschaftlich, ist es gesellschaftlich, das ist eine Frage, ist es gesellschaftlich zu tragen, tragbar, dass man, wenn man bei Paypal bezahlt, weil man ja eben nicht bar bezahlen möchte, kein Trinkgeld gibt. Ja, aber kannst du denn bei Paypal, kannst du bei Paypal dann Trinkgeld angeben? Ich als Student sage, es ist völlig okay. Kann man, bei Pizzade kann man das. Er scheint, Insiderinformationen sagen, dass es dann nicht die Leute kriegen, die es austragen. Dass wenn man tatsächlich dem Lieferboten Geld geben möchte, muss man es direkt machen. Weil die PayPal wird nie auf die Leute abgewälzt. Das habe ich gehört, habe ich gehört. Kann sein, weiß ich nicht. Ich hatte mal die sehr lustige Erfahrung, da habe ich mal mit einem Inder bestellt, habe dann mit PayPal bezahlt und der Typ kam und wollte
Bargeld haben von mir. Dann hab ich gesagt, nee, ich hab schon bezahlt.
Und er hat mir das nicht
geglaubt einfach. Er hat mir das nicht geglaubt, weil auf seiner
auf deren internen Rechnung
stand das nicht, dass ich schon bezahlt
hab. Und dann musste ich,
dann hab ich ihm die Wohnung reingebieten, war ein sehr netter
Inder-Typ
und dann hab ich
ihm meinen PC gezeigt, hab die Abrechnung gezeigt
und so, er konnte das nicht glauben, dann hab ich
ihm, er konnte auch glaube ich gar kein Deutsch
Vielen Dank. Inder-Typ. Und dann habe ich dem meinen PC gezeigt, habe die Abrechnung gezeigt und so, er konnte das nicht glauben, er konnte auch glaube ich gar kein Deutsch. Und dann sollte ich mit seinem Chef telefonieren. Dann saß halt ein Inder, der mein Essen geliefert hat, in meiner Wohnung, an meinem PC, da saß er, weil ich ihm gezeigt habe, vor meiner Abrechnung halt, vor meiner Welt schon angefangen. Er hat schon angefangen, von dem Essen zu essen? Ja, genau. Habe ich ihn darauf eingeladen. Entweder es gerade auch. Und dann habe ich mit seinem Chef telefoniert, der glaube ich dachte, dass ich der Liefertyp wäre, weil das war auch irgendwie sein erster Tag oder so. Ich wurde übel angeschissen. Machen Sie das doch ab jetzt. Ja, machen Sie das doch bitte. Und dann wurde ich sehr zu sauer gemacht von dem, habe mich dann mit Lieferheld angelegt, weil ich sauer auf die war, dass die das nicht vernünftig untergegeben haben. Welche Kohlhaus-Deu, du gehst die Leiter bis hoch zum höchsten Pizza-De-Verwalter und brenst Leipzig ab. Klar, die hatten nämlich einen Serverzusammenbruch und deswegen hat die das Geld nie erreicht. Das war nämlich die Situation. Und dann habe ich eben vom Restaurant ein Essen umsonst bekommen und von Lieferhelden Essen umsonst bekommen und es war der beste Abend meines Lebens. Ich habe einen neuen Freund in einem Inder gewonnen. Hatte zwar Hunger, habe ich zu essen bekommen, aber es war gut. Ach, wir hatten beide zu essen, ein Jahr lang. Nee, aber ich finde schon, dass sich Trinkgeld gehört. Ich bestelle mit meinem Mitbewohner ab und zu und das ist oft so, dass er dann nochmal extra zwei Euro rauskramt. Besteht es ja einen Mitbewohner? Gehe ich nicht darauf ein, dass er dann extra nochmal zwei Euro rauskramt und das dem den Lieferboten gibt. Was aber auch so ein bisschen blöd ist, wenn man, ja, dann ist es immer so, oh es klingelt, oh schnell, wir brauchen Kleingeld, Kleingeld, oh wir haben nur noch 30 Cent, kann man jetzt 30 Cent Trinkgeld geben oder nicht oder gibt man lieber gar nichts, weil es ist ja so ein Ding. Genau, das ist gut. Man kann ja, also da hatte ich eine lange Diskussion mit einem Freund von mir, weil der ist sozial komplett inkompetent, der kann gar nichts, was sowas angeht. Und wir waren auch beim Chinesen Essen und sein Essen hat 18,30 Euro gekostet und er hat sich Trinkgeld auf 18,50 Euro rausgeben lassen. Er hat 20 Cent Trinkgeld gegeben. Gut wäre, wenn man sagt, wenn man 18 Euro gibt und sagt, stimmt so. Da ist wirklich eine mehrständige Diskussion daraus erbrannt, weil er gesagt hat, ja, besser als nichts, ja, aber das stimmt nicht. Man kann, also irgendwann wird so eine Geste zur Beleidigung. Man kann nicht so wenig Trinkgeld geben, das kehrt seinen Sinn irgendwann um. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Und man hätte lieber gar kein Trinkgeld bekommen, als ganz wenig. Also meine Oma hat immer gesagt, weil den Pfennig nicht erbt, das ist taulhaftig wert. Nein, das ist Bullshit. Das ist genauso, wenn du jemandem irgendwie ein Blatt Papier zum Geburtstag schenkst. Da denkst du ja auch, fink dich, schenk mir lieber gar nichts. Das ist besser, als wenn du mir irgendeinen Scheiss schenkst. Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass ich dahinter stehe. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass meine Oma immer gesagt hat. Du kannst deine Oma hier bitte nicht mehr als Quelle benutzen, das verfälscht die Diskussion irgendwie. Es ist auch so. Du kannst deine Oma nicht einfach einbringen. Deine Oma als gedachten Diskussionspartner, wenn meine Oma jetzt hier wäre, würde die Folgendes sagen. tut nichts zur Sache, aber meine Oma würde das sagen, so geht's nicht. Es ist so, dass viele Sprichwörter auch scheiße sind. Ja, natürlich. Ich finde auch immer, wenn Leute sagen, ja, einem geschenkten Maul schaut man nicht ins, einem geschenkten Gaul schaut man nicht ins Maul, das ist auch das Dümmste überhaupt. Wenn es ein Arschlochgaul ist und der dich tötet, weil er ein Mördergaul ist, dann ist es scheiße.. Auch kaum noch Gauler, ne? Also es ist ja auch ein komplett outage. Eben, es ist auch komplett nicht mehr transferabend. Ja, vor allem, ich glaube, Sprichwörter kürzen sich komplett aus. Wenn du alle Sprich-, die Bedeutung von allen Sprichwörtern mathematisch ausdrücken würdest und alle zusammen addierst, kommt am Ende Null raus. Ich erläutere, was ich meine. Es gibt, glaube ich, zu jeder Situation wie so ein Wissenschafts-Podcast. Es gibt zu jeder Situation zwei Sprichwörter, die genau das Gegenteil zeigen. Zum Beispiel, ah, keine Ahnung, ich habe mich da in diese Frau verliebt, aber die ist ja ganz anders als ich, wir haben ja keine gleichen Hobbys. Und dann sagt ihr, haha, Gegensätze ziehen sich an. Aber es gibt auch das Sprichwort, gleich und gleich gesellt sich gern. Von daher, fick dich, du bist komplett auf dich alleine gestellt. Die wunderbare Welt der Sprichwörter kann dir nicht helfen, weil es einfach zwei gibt, es gleicht sich aus, am Ende null. Sprichwörter sind einfach so ein Lückenfüller für Dinge, die du ausrücken willst, um dir so eine gewisse Tragkraft zu geben, aber eigentlich haben Sprichwörter an selbst keine Weisheit oder keinen Inhalt an sich.
Um dann nochmal auf diese Lieferhalt-Sache zurückzukommen.
Was ist gesellschaftlich erlaubt?
Ich finde, dadurch, dass man jetzt bestellen kann, Essen, hat sich eine ganz neue Gesellschaft, eine ganz neue Normen haben sich entwickelt.
Werte und Normen sind komplett umgeschrieben worden.
Weil ich kann ja jetzt auch bei einer Pizzeria bestellen, die fünf Meter entfernt ist.
Mache ich teilweise sogar, weil ich einfach faul bin. Aber ich glaube, das ist ihnen lieber, als wenn sie weit fahren müssen. Das ist ja kein Problem. Ja gut, hätten wir das geklärt. Aber, die lustige ist, was ja, wie hieß die Sendung nochmal mit Jan Böhrmann und Jan Köppen und RTL, wenn nicht du wäre, nee, warte mal, was wäre wenn? Da haben die es ja auch so gemacht, dass sie zur Pizzerie gegangen sind und sich eine Pizza nach Hause haben bestellen lassen und dann mit dem Boten mitgefahren sind. Supergut. Ja, also nur als Kleine, ja wenn du deine Oma, wenn du deine scheiß Oma als Quelle einbichst, dann bringe ich, was wäre, wenn als fiktiven Gesprächspartner ins Spiel. Fick dich mal, hier kannst du ja vergessen. Was ist das für eine Scheissaktion hier von dir? Aber bestellen ist tatsächlich so eine Sache. Vor allem mein Mitbewohner, er gründet auch gerade das Bestellen von ganz normalen Haushaltseinkäufen. Also man kann ja auch bei Edeka bestellen, dann ganz normale Sachen. Und da bin ich ja tatsächlich abgeneigt. Das finde ich ist dann schon lame, weil natürlich bestellt er dann... Warum? Naja, natürlich bestellt er dann möglichst schw möglichst schwere Dinge, irgendwie Getränke, einen Kasten Bier, einen Sandwichmaker, einfach weil er weiss, irgendein scheiss Pakistani muss den ganzen Shit in vierten Stock hochtragen und ich nicht. Natürlich ist es verständlich, aber irgendwie finde ich, kratzen wir da echt nah an Sklavenarbeit ran, weil das ist eigentlich schon scheisse.
Natürlich, wenn es jemand anbietet und die Leute suchen ja auch den Job aus,
aber irgendwie, finde ich, hat man auch irgendwie eine Verantwortung gegenüber Mitmenschen.
Und wenn du unbedingt deine scheiß Evian zwei Liter Flaschen, 18 Stück am Tag trinken willst,
dann trag sie auch selber die Treppe hoch.
Also da muss ich jetzt auch mal ein bisschen polemisch werden, weil ich finde, das funktioniert einfach so nicht. Okay, ich bin dankbar für das Statement, da haben wir wieder was gelernt, was du da im Kopf hast. Aber das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr zum Beispiel in den Buchladen gehst, ich habe ein Weihnachtsgeschenk von meiner Mutter gebraucht und hatte wenig Zeit. Ganz kurz, Buchladen, Buchladen, was war das noch? Ich glaube, die verkaufen Schallplatten, das war so ein grosser Automat. Buchladen, sind das diese Franchise, diese Unternehmen, die wirken wie Franchiseunternehmen von Amazon? Genau, genau, sowas. Das war ein Buchhandel. Das war die Bundesbankgrüne, glaube ich, erst vor kurzem, so Amazon-Stores. Auf jeden Fall geht man da hin und dann habe ich ein Buch gesucht, weil ich es direkt gebraucht habe, hatte keine Wartezeit. Fifty Shades of Grey. Genau, ja, das hat ja meine Mutter geschrieben und spielt mit. Und dann hatten die das Buch nicht und dann gehe ich so hin, ja, haben Sie dieses Buch? Und dann sagt sie, nein, aber ich kann es bestellen. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut, ich kann es aber auch selber bestellen. Stimmt. Also ist nett von Ihnen, aber eigentlich gar nichts auf selber. Aber vor allem auch, was für ein Angebot, ne? Wir bestellen es, damit du nochmal extra in ein Buchladen musst, um es abzuholen, anstatt dass es einfach zu dir nach Hause bestellt wird. Also das ist ja schon komisch, dass man auch das anbieten würde. Ich meine, wenn da jetzt irgendwie eine alte Oma ist und die keine Ahnung von Amazon hat, aber einem jungen Mann anzubieten, dass man es in die Buchhandlung bestellt, ist schon ein bisschen komisch, ne? Das ist so ein bisschen, ich biete dir einen Dienst an, der schlechter ist als das, was du selber machen könntest. Aber das machen die ja oft halt, die müssen ja auch an ihre eigene Existenz denken. Und das ist ja nämlich dieser Catchphrase, wo ich früher immer sehr dankbar war, wenn ich mir dachte, hey, ich gehe jetzt in den Buchladen und ich suche was und wenn die das nicht haben, dann können sie es bestellen. Und ich war immer mit so einer positiven Einstellung, bin ich in Buchläden gegangen, weil ich immer bekommen habe, innerhalb der nächsten Tage, was ich wollte. Das ist nicht bei allen Läden der Fall. Wenn es nicht da ist, ist es oft meistens einfach nicht da. Und dann bei Theuser Ass zum Beispiel, ich war auch früher bei Theuser Ass, habe Tage da verbracht, weil ich als Einzelkind halt, muss man sehen, wo man bleibt. Und dann, wenn ein Spielzeug nicht da war, haben die gesagt, ja gut, es kommt halt irgendwann mit der nächsten Lieferung. Wann ist die? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Und Buchhandlungen konnten immer genau sagen, morgen haben sie es. Ja, irgendwie hat man schon das Gefühl, dass Bücher schneller reisen als andere Gegenstände. Dass Bücher immer total eine krasse, gute Infrastruktur haben, die sofort da sind mit so einem Röhrensystem oder irgendwie Ratten. Die haben einfach die bessere Lobby. Bücher hatten immer schon die bessere Lobby und Spielsachen an sich waren immer schon scheiße eigentlich. Jetzt habe ich meine Frage an dich. Hast du schon mal, bist du schon mal in ein Gespräch eingetreten mit einem Verkäufer, ohne zu wissen, was du kaufen willst? Also Beispiel, ich habe letztens gesehen diese, wo ich auch noch nie war, diese Buden, wo man Karten kaufen kann für Theaterstücke und Konzerte und sowas, na kennst du die, wo man dann live hingeht. Und da frage ich mich, wie oft geht da jemand hin und sagt, ach was läuft denn heute Abend, ich hätte Lust auf was Lustiges. Und dann muss die arme Studentin irgendwie dem Typen da sagen, ja wir haben Mario Barth oder Atze Schröder oder was mögen sie denn gerne, aber passiert sowas? Also hast du das schon mal gemacht oder dass du zu einer Buchhandlung gegangen hast und ich hätte Lust auf irgendeine spannende Geschichte, die in der Wüste spielt, was haben sie denn da?
Ich würde nämlich auch als Verkäufer erwarten, dass derjenige, der reinkommt, weiss, was er will. Und das ist so ein, das habe ich so, diesen Anspruch habe ich auch an mich selber, weil ich auch bei Subway zum Beispiel, da traue ich mich nicht zu fragen, wenn sie fragt, ja, was haben sie denn, was haben sie denn für einen Soßen Wunsch, dann traue ich mich nicht zu sagen, bei sich nicht, was haben sie denn, sondern ich fühle mich verpflichtet zu wissen, was da für Soßen stehen. Das ist auch ein Zeichen von Schwäche, das ist ein Zeichen von Schwäche. Nee, von dir, wenn du nicht weißt, was du da willst. Nee, zuzugeben ist nicht zu wissen, genau, genau. Richtig, genau, deswegen sage ich immer, irgendwas zu los. Ich finde, das ist ein soziales Problem, weil das bringt den in eine ganz komische Situation, also mit diesem Kartengeschäft, das bringt eine andere Person in die Situation, dass die andere Person dafür verantwortlich ist, wie unterhaltsam dein Abend wird. Oh, Telefon. Das ist ein Indikling. Nein, das ist mein Festnetztelefon. Und das finde ich eine komische Situation, wenn der andere dafür verantwortlich ist, weil der weiss ja überhaupt nichts über den Menschen. Ich meine, gerade bei Kunstangeboten gibt es ja wahnsinnig unterschiedliche Dinge. Nur wenn man sich für Comedy interessiert, kann man Habe Kerkeling total gut und als der Schröder total scheisse finden. Und es ist eine riesige Verantwortung, die auf der Person lastet, die ich niemals einer Person anvertrauen würde. Also nie. Aber gibt es, aber wirklich, da würde ich mal ganz aufrufen, seid ihr solche Leute? Was seid ihr für Leute? Schreibt doch einfach mal, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, schreibt doch jetzt einfach mal eine Facebook-Nachricht oder irgendwie sowas und beschreibt euch mal, was für Leute ihr seid und versucht mal irgendwie Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten zu geben, welche Leute ihr seid, auf Facebook oder so. Schreibt mal sowas wie ich bin jemand, der geht in einen Laden und sagt, ach, ich hätte Lust auf sowas ähnliches wie Star Wars, nur vielleicht mit ein bisschen mehr Erotik. Haben Sie sowas? Mich würde interessieren, wie alt seid ihr? Nein, das ist scheiße, das Alter sagt doch heute überhaupt nichts mehr über die Person aus. Es gibt heute mit einem 20-Jährigen, die die Hauptprogramms Comedy-Autoren sind, ja, das sagt doch überhaupt nichts, wie eine Person beschaffen ist und die Persönlichkeit in den Charakteren. Es sagt aber, wie qualifiziert die dafür sind und dass viele falsch gelaufen sind. Ja, das stimmt. Nee, man sollte, ich möchte wissen, wie alt seid ihr? Was habt ihr sonst so für Hobbys? Ich will nicht wissen, wie ihr alt seid. Wie seid ihr auf uns gestossen? Über eine Suchmaschine, über Freunde. Oder seid ihr in den Buchhandel gegangen und sagt, ich hätte so einen Podcast irgendwie gesagt, ich mag es anfangs sorgfältig, aber vielleicht ein bisschen schlafen. Haben Sie da was?
Haben Sie da nicht irgendwas?
Ohne Scheiss, sind wir nicht, wir sind glaube ich im Schatten, wir sind wirklich im Schatten von sorgfältig, weil wir, man kann uns ja, also wenn ich jetzt angenommen, ich will jetzt ein Buch und ich will ein religiöses Buch lesen, dann lese ich ja nicht, dann angenommen, dann kauft man doch die Bibel, man kauft doch die Bibel, man kauft doch nicht das Wesen, das kleine Buch daneben, so die Bibel zwei, irgendwie von zwei schlechteren Autoren oder so, das kauft man nicht, man liest die Bibel und wenn man uns, wenn man Podcast hören will, dann hört man offensichtlich den besseren Podcast und nicht uns. Das ist eigentlich das zweitbestverkaufte christliche Buch, also irgendjemand muss da sitzen und sagen, Alter, ich bin direkt nach Gott, ich bin Nummer zwei, erstens Gott und zweitens ich. Ich meine, wie gut muss das denn sein? Das Zweite Testament? So funktioniert das nicht, Stefan. Nein, ist das nicht die Fortsetzung? Ich glaube, es kommt noch ein Prequel raus jetzt irgendwann. Nee, ich glaube, das Zweite Testament ist doch das Prequel, aber ohne Jesus, da waren sehr viele enttäuscht, glaube ich, damals. Aber gibt es eigentlich Bibel-Fanfiction, also gibt es Leute, die die Bibel weitergeführt haben oder Prequels oder sowas oder irgendwie so einen alternativen Ausgang oder sowas in der Richtung? Also einer der besten Tweets. Moses hat das Wasser geteilt. Oh Gott, schon wieder. Aber einer der besten Tweets, die ich letztens gelesen habe, war, wie geil wäre es, wenn auf der letzten Seite der Bibel die letzte Zeile lautet, man muss wahrscheinlich dabei gewesen sein. Das finde ich so gut. Das finde ich so ein guter Gang. Stell dir das mal vor. Ja, wahrscheinlich muss man dabei gewesen sein. So am Ende von so einem ewig langen Buch so, ach weisst du, wahrscheinlich muss man dabei gewesen sein.
Das ist gut. So ein guter Gap, ey. Scherz. Scherz. Spaß. Das ist auch nicht so schlecht, so ein Riesenbuch zu schreiben, so alles hängt irgendwie miteinander zusammen, alles ergibt irgendwie Sinn am Ende, nur ach, war ein Scheiß. Das habe ich mich immer gefragt, warum es wichtig ist, wie Bücher enden. Na also zum Beispiel, wenn dann irgendwie bei Herr der Ringe oder so steht im Silmarillion oder irgend so in diesen komischen anderen Büchern, sogar im Herr der Ringe, dass irgendwann Legolas und Gimli irgendwie zusammenziehen, irgendwie ein Kind adoptieren und dann sterben die irgendwann. Und dann habe ich mit jemandem gesprochen, der sagt, oh, ich fand das so traurig, dass am Ende Legolas gestorben ist. Und ich dachte, es ist doch scheissegal, was auf der letzten Seite des Buchs steht,
ob fünf Minuten nach dem Abspann die Figur stirbt oder nicht.
Das ist doch scheissegal.
Wichtig ist es doch was...
Weil mit Gimli, der zieht mit Gimli zusammen?
Der zieht mit Gimli zusammen, ja, das ist ja so die grosse Story von Herr der Ring.
Gegensätze ziehen sich an, anscheinend doch.
Da hat Tolkien dann doch recht gehabt.
Jetzt hat er mich verloren, jetzt hat mich Tolkien verloren.
Ja, total, aber das habe ich auch nie verstanden.
Wenn man dann irgendwie schreiben würde, oder wenn J.K. Rowling jetzt sagen würde,
Übersetzung der ZDF-Gesetz. Doch, da hat Tolkien dann doch recht gehabt. Jetzt hat er mich verloren, jetzt hat mich Tolkien verloren. Ja, total, aber das habe ich auch nie verstanden. Wenn man dann irgendwie schreiben würde oder wenn J.K. Rowling jetzt sagen würde, übrigens acht Minuten nach Abblende erleidet Hermine Granger einen Herzinfarkt. Nein, oh mein Gott, du hast Hermine getötet. Mir egal. Also sag ich, Ismir. Das war übrigens das Fieseste, was ich jemals gemacht habe. Ich bin in den ersten Harry Potter gegangen von den zwei Teilen am Ende. Ja, also der vorletzte. Ich bin quasi in den vorletzten, genau. Das wird so einfach gewesen, sozusagen. Ich bin in den vorletzten Harry Potter gegangen, bin reingelaufen, habe einigermaßen in der letzten Reihe gesessen, alle haben sich schon hingesetzt, das Licht ging gerade so runter, ich habe mir auch meine Jacke ausgezogen, auf den Tisch gelegt und gesagt, ach ja, Dobby stirbt, habe ich ihn gesetzt. Hast du das wirklich gemacht? Ich habe es wirklich gemacht. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum, ich glaube, es war eine Wette oder so. Ich habe ganz laut das Ried gerufen. Ach ja, das war der Film, in dem Dobby stirbt. Aber hast du es als Ankündigung gesagt oder hast du es so getan, als würde es in einem Gespräch entstehen? Ja, ich glaube, es war so etwas wie, ach ja, das war der Film, in dem Dobby stirbt, so als ob es gerade jemand gefragt und man antwortet viel zu laut. Ja, vor allem, was ist die Frage, stirbt Dobby in diesem Film? Ja, und dann auch noch mal die Frage wiederholen, damit sie jeder verstanden hat. Ja, genau. Nee, und das kam nicht gut an, aber ich glaube, die meisten wussten das schon.
Also die sind in den Film reingegangen, haben sich gut informiert, das Buch nicht mal gelesen, zur Vorsicht. Apropos jetzt, apropos Buchlesen, ich habe gelesen eben, dass sich, dass Baumarktmitarbeiter wurden jetzt gebeten, Fifty Shades of Grey zu lesen, bevor der Film in die Kimos kommt, weil da erwartet wird, dass sehr viele Leute so SM-Sachen im Nachhinein im Baumarkt kaufen wollen. Dass sie einen Keller einrichten oder Sachen reinbauen. Genau, genau. Und dass sich die Baumarkt-Mitarbeiter, um fachkundig mit Rat zur Seite zu stehen, stehen zu können, dass sie sich deshalb das Buch durchlesen sollen und sich darüber informieren sollen. Wie gut ist das denn? Nicht so schlecht, ne? Das ist ja grossartig. Ja, das ist so grossartig, das ist auch irgendwie dann auch kein Witz mehr. Da kann man jetzt auch nicht, keinen Gag mal drauf zu machen, weil es einfach an sich schon lustig ist. Ja, aber dann gehen eine Menge Frauen in die Baumarkt und sagen, also ich weiß nicht, ob sie sowas da haben. Ich hätte irgendwie gern so einen Sexkeller. Meine Freundin hätte gerne. Ja, haben wir da, hier können wir, haben wir von Bosch, haben wir da, hier haben wir eine Bohrmaschine. Haben wir fertig, wir haben fertig Sexkeller. Aber es ist natürlich auch unangenehm. Ich glaube, es ist ganz gut, als wenn man dann so reingeht, ja, was brauchen Sie denn? Also ich bräuchte ein paar Handschellen, irgendwie so ein paar Ketten von der Decke, was wollen Sie denn bauen? Ja, für die Vögel draußen im Garten brauchen wir so ein paar Peitschen und so. Das ist auch blöd, man kann ja da natürlich auch einfacher drüber reden. Ja, man kann da nicht drüber reden. Da ergibt dann auch die Geschichten, mit denen man sich da rausbringen will, ergeben auch keinen Sinn. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Hattest du schon mal ... Wir sind vom Thema abgekommen. Wir sind vom Thema abgekommen. Wir müssen nächste Woche bitte nochmal Prüfen nehmen, weil ich habe noch ein paar Sachen in der Flage. Ja, Prüfen habe ich tatsächlich auch noch eine. Ja, Prüfen war wesentlich ergiebiger als liefern, ne, irgendwie, kann es sein? Liefern hat nicht so gewillert. Wir sind heute, haben gute Themen gehabt zwar, aber es ist immer so, wenn wir Scheißthemen haben, bleiben wir nur bei diesen Themen. Ja, genau, wenn gute Themen haben, schweifle ab. Und wegen uns überhaupt, dass die Scheiße sind. Genau, das ist immer so. Ja, stimmt. Was soll's, was soll's, wir sind alle noch in der Übungsphase, für uns alle das erste Mal. Auch für euch Publikum, vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit und bis zum nächsten Mal. Nächste Woche haben wir vielleicht eigentlich einen Gast. Schon langsam müssen wir unser Gast kommen. Du bist ja immer Gegengast, ich bin immer für Gast, deswegen könnt ihr jetzt eigentlich live verfolgen, wer sich durchsetzen wird bei uns. Aber ansonsten, folgt uns auf Twitter. Es hat sich gerade in der Dropbox Podcast-Ideen organisiert. Ja, weil ich die Themen gelöscht habe, wie ich die angesprochen habe. Ist das professionell? Ich finde das immer super. Ich finde es immer gut, wenn sich, das ist wie so ein Hirn, du kannst die Hirnvorgänge, kannst du aktiv am PC sehen. Die Dropbox, die Podcast-Ideen haben sich aktualisiert. Das ist sehr gut. Ja. Toll. Ja, auch von mir, Dankeschön, dass Sie es wieder ausgehalten haben mit uns. Folgt uns auf Twitter, folgt uns auf Facebook und schreibt uns eine gute iTunes-Bewertung. Und Stefan wünscht euch noch einen schönen Abend, bis zum nächsten Mal. Aber jetzt hoffen wir, dass wir wieder regelmässiger aufnehmen können. Es hängt natürlich auch ein bisschen an Stefan, der jetzt endlich seinen Abschluss durch hat und jetzt direkt seinen Abschluss, wo man direkt bei Elite-Partner eingereiht wird. Ich muss den noch unterbringen, tut mir leid. Boah, das ist so ein schlechter Gag. Der Gag ist nicht schlecht. Der Gag ist doch nicht schlecht. Die Vorstellung, dass jemand nur einen Abschluss macht, um zu Elite-Partners zu kommen, finde ich ist okay.
Ja, aber es ist halt schlecht performt. Da kann ich gut von gehen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut, ciao.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Wir heben ab, wir müssen zurück in den Zeitstrudel. Thank you.